I think it would be well useful
especially for some of our younger
viewers who might not remember those
earliest days of YouTube to just Glimpse
back at a second as to what it used to
look like it was very you know before
monetization and professionalization was
very much just like your amateurs
uploading just a dumb video you took and
kind of the the prime I mean we can just
look at the very first video that was
put up the one of the founders kind of
set the tone for early YouTube uh the uh
this is uh here we are one of the
elephants
they have really really really long
prompts and that's that's cool
[Music]
and that's pretty much all there is to
say
no no disinformation there that is an
absolute truth elephants do have a lot
of drugs absolutely that's got a I think
a couple hundred million views uh racked
up by now but yeah you know uh we wanted
to talk about uh you know before we get
into some of the negatives that your
documentary raises could you talk a
little bit about YouTube's upsides what
are some of the the best contributions
to I know our culture to video and
filmmaking that you think uh YouTube has
made over the years
there are so many uh and Google as well
and I I sort of mentioned them in the
same breath because they really are one
company even though there are elements
to YouTube that that are separate um
uh they are really one company with with
a with a single ethos and uh and the
kind and I'd say the positives of that
are are a commitment to
um
to Innovation and kind of human
evolution using the culture itself uh as
its primary product
um and I think a lot of that has been uh
extremely vitally important to Global
culture um in in some ways so in such
vast ways that it's almost diminishes
its power to start to break apart little
things like oh it's helpful to figure
out how to put AAA batteries into the
back of your radio it's like you know it
gives you like mundane information well
it's also the repository of basically
all a visual human content that's ever
existed since the dawn of content being
recorded in any form and even not
recorded um you know but re-implemented
in some form another by the way of
explainers so it's it's our last it is
our library Alexandria I know that's a a
terrifying concept especially to
Librarians because there is so much
misinformation there but there were
there were a lot of there was a lot of
information in the Library of Alexandria
too right there was and there's a lot of
misinformation in your in your local
public library so that's just and that's
sort of my point is where I get kind of
you know uh disconcerted by the way we
look at at the rise of new technology
having been around these stores for a
long time is we other it right it's this
other thing but it's not another thing
it's really a natural evolution of human
uh uh Innovation and these are tools
that that we have evolved to create
um and they're just a part of the fabric
of Being Human so YouTube specifically I
would credit them with as I said earlier
with very specifically and intentionally
monetizing the democratization of
culture something that we saw happening
with Napster that the record industry I
would argue still has not successfully
done as well as YouTube has done I would
even argue that my industry which is on
strike right now has not figured it out
as well as YouTube has uh you can you
can create on YouTube you can be a trans
you know African artist in a in a micro
nation and make a crazy good living if
you have access to these tools and can
uh you will get monetized you'll build
an audience you'll you the gates are
down you're reaching people all over the
world
um and so that's an amazing thing that I
think they did intentionally and very
successfully I think the breadth of
information is vitally important to have
at the fingertips of anyone around the
world it just removes gatekeeping and it
removes uh it democratizes information
yeah unless you're in China where they
can literally censor you right uh and I
mean just to kind of build on that the
you know one of the early Sensations on
YouTube was watching Chinese kids uh lip
syncing to the Backstreet Boys songs and
things like that and it created you're a
gangman style the rise of K-pop yeah I
mean it created a a global village right
that Marshall mcluhan could only kind of
speculate about in the 60s and it built
off of the you know those signal
developments in the 90s that were a lot
of it was around the internet but it was
other you know just the the uh
decreasing price of uh technology so
that you know the the cost produce and
consume culture under whatever
circumstances you wanted as the
production costs and consumption costs
of of media become cheaper we could look
back at this for 500 years or 50 years
or 10 years
um participatory culture seems to be the
answer
um make the final case like how should
people get off the sidelines in order to
enter the scrum to fight for the world
that they want is YouTube the medium for
that uh primarily or
I think that you know and this is maybe
a it's not an intentionally provocative
thing to say but I think people need to
lean into these Technologies and not
away from them I think that they're a
big part of our life and you have to get
involved I know my kids are safe because
I'm on YouTube I know who these people I
know who the good apples are in the bad
it's like that's parenting right it's
just like I wouldn't send my kid into a
neighborhood without knowing the
neighborhood or let them be with someone
that I didn't think was safe
um all three of my kids have been on
YouTube their entire life not one of
them got like black killed or red pill
or whatever whatever it is the kids say
um so uh it's you know I think leaning
in
um I think having an awareness of these
Technologies are not necessarily good or
bad they are just a part of human
evolution and Innovation so be part of
them use them understand them be
Discerning uh so I think that you're in
their participation can come from
wherever like you were saying about
Contra points like it comes from
wherever your strength is
um and and and really understanding
what's going on in the world in sort of
a broad way that was an excerpt from our
conversation with Alex Winter the
director of the new documentary the
YouTube effect tell us what you think in
the comments and if you want to see
another excerpt go here if you want to
see the whole conversation and you
should go here and make sure to come
back every Thursday at 1 pm on Eastern
Time
to check out a new live stream from
reason TV